this is a studio logo or part of the
credits I will admit to being an
American and thereby not knowing about
what language this is or what this
symbol means but I'm genuinely concerned
about radiation levels at this point
reading 800,000 students boycotted the
school in the juvenile crime area
daunted last allcomp okay I'm sorry I'm
already lost class pictures so lucky on
any narration which happens moms leave
no need to be a pussy about it dropping
something to signify shock cliche toilet
paper suicide note why would he take the
time to ensure his TP suicide note rolls
perfectly into the bathroom oh is it so
we could see him puke got it not let the
same look I could have dated oh damn it
is this entire movie gonna be a non
American adult male on Middle School Bus
sitting in the back row between two
playful girls
that is definitely a sin even if I do
the same thing in his position uh-huh
foreshadowing we're bad guys desks done
you got doc Cottle did you mean the
teacher from two years ago one of these
guys just said I saw as though there was
any debate but damn if you taught him
two years ago there is ZERO debate about
your identity but whatever these two new
classmates just before the big death
competition will probably not directly
impact the big death competition later
we find out the battle royale has been
going on for a few years now and it gets
tons of media coverage so how can they
not know what kind of movie am I
watching here do they own little money
oh I don't know if it's something lost
in the English translation but what and
I you stole that Jocelyn I said oh no
holy talk pretty much done
well don't know out of roll credits
uncle Barney was there
Gaetano would be excellent at cinema
Sid's cute video girl confuses
everything now there's satire mixing
with extreme violence and there's a
tingling of my penis all strange
sensations to be feeling at once this
video suggests there's a website for the
battle royale which is simple enough in
and of itself that these students are
unaware of it but also they somehow
managed to snag BR calm away from Baskin
Robbins off dude
man this dude is dedicated to the VCR
controls he paused that as soon as
Kitano killed that girl he is on point
foreshadowing photograph just happens to
be on the floor next to Nobu so we can
see the cleverness of the foreshadowing
these girls appear turned on by death or
sorrow why did the eerily prescient
adults lay down plastic wrap on only
half this room's floor and this game
should be easy to win if you're the
first person call wants to prevent the
first person from running to the exit
and just waiting for each unprepared
student to come out and just kill him
right there at least in The Hunger Games
everybody got to go at the same time
lucky for the class the wimpiest kid is
the first one they call BFFs well jeez
is the movie can announce every kid
before the killing starts skip wait
aren't those two in love or something
well that's not the traditional
definition of deep throating but i think
technically it still works this is all
happening right outside where all the
kids are running out so thank God for
the crazy delay in kids running out
right now so that only this one fat kid
has to die I guess we better get a
cannon ready
jeez if it's just a scratch why is her
sleeve soaked in blood annal reales I
dick to random kids hoping to murder
each other dude that was the signal
second base is open for the taking what
are you waiting for director had an
obvious disagreement with actor over
exactly how much this character loved
reading well we're in a cave and no
one's looking I think I could taste it
oh you meant the bag of cookies didn't
you Jesus a digital map of each
contestant on the playing field I'd say
something about The Hunger Games being a
ripoff here but I'd be in danger ripping
off my own video from earlier when I
called The Hunger Games a ripoff of this
story
jeez a fan I'm not sure if the people
running battle royale have a sense of
humor or if they're just assholes they
could be the guys behind cinemasins for
all I know the iconic game
morals these two conscientious objectors
are so distraught about the game that
they kill themselves instead of I don't
know cake decorating themselves to look
like trees and merely hiding the entire
competition
whoa okay so this is basically Hunger
Games meets Kill Bill whoever made this
movie likes girls and skirts which is
fine as a starting point and comically
violent blood spurting this is not a
healthy combination of interests
every time someone dies the movie
interrupts itself to tell us the
audience at home who it was and how many
kids are left why do you warn them
before coming out of the bushes and do
it before they even get to your hiding
place place in the woods as a super-long
Hill to fall down cliche yes
math threatening also damn they gave at
least five people some guns in this but
thought it was really funny to include
fans pans and binoculars for the others
this idiot charges at a guy holding a
shotgun on it the guy was fucking
yelling how could you possibly know this
girl is still moving after being riddled
with hundreds of bullets this is a funny
line but it's not really a good idea
since the rule state you'll die anyway
if you run out of time and you're not
the last person standing
posted that period chair haha gross also
what the actual fuck this chick checked
a dead body to see if that dead person
had previously been having her monthly
cycle
laziness also what is wrong with this
girl that she's suddenly unable to walk
and did I miss an illness
this guy says so that's their trick out
loud but then starts typing as if he
didn't just give the Battle Royale
control room a huge clue that he figured
the shit out also why don't the battle
royale people make shelters like this a
danger zone
I give them any place where they might
be able to plot stuff like this this guy
is the right idea jeez it's good
hilarious English translation is
hilarious homicidal girl kills the
element of surprise and waits way too
long to shoot this other girl I can see
the dead body breathing I care about
this young romance tragedy but I'm
honestly still freaked out by the period
checker girl oh my God where does a
ninth grader get a fucking flask of
alcohol wait never mind I just remember
my uncle Greg also an older former gang
contestant joining the game damn
besides the tampon checking is there
anything in this movie The Hunger Games
didn't steal everyone who died in this
particular battle royale died in this
very same spot they should have known
not to come here this place is cursed
with the blood of all the ninth graders
I had to rewind this four times to
figure out what happened even if that
means exhuming her body for questioning
my little lost in there right my water
here sound oh gosh don't you Oh cue
character is only waiting to say the
important thing because the screenwriter
told him to the psycho killer can keep
up with a bicycle on foot but somehow
misses the dude riding it at point-blank
range what a tragic dumbass
victim stance stolen screams instead of
runs when he sees a guy with a blade
characters trying to hide make a stupid
noise so the villain can be alerted to
their presence cliche I know this is a
bad guy so he probably has terrible aim
but those bullets are also pretty should
be about going through wood right okay
wow he's not terrible at aiming he's
worse than Adrian Peterson is at
disciplining his children unlimited ammo
guy conveniently runs out at the perfect
time for this asshole to get shot by
another conveniently-placed guy did they
hire the t1000 to kill the kids yeah
people who should know better loudly
speak into their mics about secret bomb
ingredients oh then do that no no don't
yeah now it's the time to shut your
friends up I'm gonna get us a table done
your uncle was Guy Fawkes
Irv II if you can keep them from
eavesdropping by covering the necklace
microphone with your hand then what was
the point of all the silent typing out
earlier this is horrifying
I'll admit but why are they naked did
she put them and then mutilate their
genitals I'm just playing this out here
you're the one showing me the visual but
it had to happen somehow right why did
they agree to fucking such a wide open
in filthy space during a death
competition man it's almost like there's
not a death competition going on right
now hey I don't know if shuya killed
that guy on purpose or not better kill
him on purpose just to make sure this
girl is addictive shoo your spaghetti
but she dies so it's cool oh that
gunshot he hurt but not the machine gun
fire a second ago right these girls
can't shoot for shit but after 30
seconds of misses somehow all end up
with direct hits I think it means you're
winning dude teacher-student relations
this is for the people who can read lips
and Japanese will never know what kind
of horrible dirty things they said to
each other previously in the movie
you're watching right now how does she
know he's even around here right now
what the hell is this guy doing out here
would you like a popsicle wait he showed
up to scare away the mean chicken give
her an umbrella dude if you're gonna
directly interfere with the death
competition you yourself are running
don't you think it could bring a little
more to the table god I am so confused
as to whether any of these people are
important have we even seen some of
these people yet and maybe mine loud
yelling I only give myself one-tenth the
blame I had no idea you'd start blasting
half the people in this game got ink
pens or the wheel of fortune home game
as weapons I had a 50/50 chance and I
would like to buy a vowel see me I'm
gonna walk backwards for no reason now
because there surely someone behind me
ready to shoot that I can't see and
everyone showed up for the big finale at
relatively the same time movie continues
to strain its bullet realism just
because this character was a badass
doesn't mean the bullet should hurt less
did this guy really just go outside with
an umbrella for basically no reason a
minute ago I mean I agree he's a
somewhat sympathetic character but what
the hell was he doing out there hacking
and bomb-making take roughly the same
amount of time and no one in the control
room could hear through our mics because
we're blocking them with our soundproof
fingers everyone keeps running into
everyone else except these three
assholes who no one ever stumbles on or
finds or talks to or anything because
bomb I don't know maybe from the three
people who were in that one place for so
long which you've never made a danger
zone the whole time this is a terrible
threat to be honest not only is this
some truly remarkable she faked typing
but I'm pretty sure this guy had never
seen a keyboard before in his life
before shooting this movie oh yeah
come on you have only yourself to blame
I think half the students in this class
are barely functional they have amazing
skills at being dumb watch after a whole
movie of being a terminator this guy is
totally gonna get killed now I probably
didn't kill him
he has emergency backup power for sure
not to mention all the souls of the
people he killed finally we get a look
at the control room and what they can
hear and they didn't hear one thing that
made them suspicious during the hacking
bomb-making session I don't care how
many times they were shown blocking
their mics those guys fucked up enough
to where you or me or a four year old
would have been suspicious of those
dudes in a government sanctioned battle
royale how does one person have all the
power to prevent someone from confirming
kills my Co Nevada Scottish thither Oh
annachi I ain't gotta hug Kings I did
understand that wait allow me when I
have stole my thunder so this is a
confusing part of the movie but we'll
just assume the Kawana knew how to
disable the necklaces the problem is how
do they know that no army guys would
show up to confirm the kills that was a
huge leap of faith what he she just one
area another law I tell you but um I
don't know this painting represents
everything katana enjoys killing kids
and falling in love with kids movie
inadvertently inspires the parents last
words become important to the plot thing
from signs it takes over a hundred
bullets to stop anyone in this fucking
movie I don't know that you have HD who
will shoot me when I try to shoot down I
sure I'm glad we got to the bottom of
that smile mystery I know this is Japan
and probably should be expected but why
does the Tower Records vending machine
sell beverages
the young girl in the schoolgirl uniform
is a Rennes personal bodyguard the go-go
Yubari gogo may be young but what she
lacks an age she makes up for in men do
you know how easy this is for me do you
have any fuckin idea how easy this is a
joke Auto is shown in Africa okey here's
a useful lesson for you give up just
quit because in this life you can't win
yeah you can try but in the end you're
just gonna lose big time because the
world is run by the man so do you need
guns lots of guns
the Jets are gonna have the date tonight
the Jets are gonna have their waves in
aah what are you doing up surprise eggs
football practice
cute baby ducks are cute I hate cute I
want to be exotic and mysterious you are
you're exotic and mysterious and cute
and you're one you're my MA
my name is Lorraine Lorraine Baines yeah
but you are you're so uh you're so thin
just relax Calvin you've got a big
bruise on your head I have no idea to
this day what those two Italian ladies
were singing about truth is I don't want
to know I can't feel my legs
cousin don't say
mm-hm